we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman the joe biden
administration has already done
so much that i want to spend time today
focusing on that but we should talk
about the inauguration which happened
yesterday
it was notable in that it was very
different than past inaugurations for a
number of reasons it took place during a
global hundred year pandemic and so the
crowd was
very very small and the entire national
mall which would often be filled with
people
to different degrees depending on which
inauguration we're talking about as we
know the crowd size
of inaugurations has been a flash point
in the past empty with flags instead
the outgoing president wasn't there for
the first time in 152 years donald trump
fleeing washington dc for palm beach
florida
early in the morning yesterday but joe
biden was sworn in there were no
incidents of violence there were no
arrests or unrest in the area just the
new presidency and vice president kamala
harris being sworn in here
um supreme court justice sonya sotomayor
does mispronounce kamala's name as
kamala
no one's perfect i expect that there
will be much of that in the next few
years
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do
solemnly swear kamala davey harris
solemnly swear
that i will support and defend the
constitution of the united states that i
will support
and defend the constitution against
all enemies foreign and domestic against
all enemies
born and domestic that i will bear true
faith
and allegiance to the same that i will
bear true faith and allegiance to the
same
that i take this obligation freely that
i take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge
that i will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office
on which i am about to enter the duties
of the office upon which i am about
to enter so help me god so help me god
and then joe biden also sworn in by the
chief justice of the supreme court john
roberts
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute that i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability the
world to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend preserve
protect and defend
the constitution of the united states
constitution of the united states
so help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there it is trump out biden in biden
giving a speech focused on unity the rea
the the pragmatic uh reality is there
will likely not be the unity biden calls
for
but biden calling for it not mentioning
trump once but mentioning the big
challenges that lie ahead of the country
for the country including starting to be
respected again by the world
dealing with the virus and more here is
joe biden talking about that
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we're
all are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart biden
directly attacking the deceptive
and pernicious disinformation that has
become
standard during trumpian america
about which during which we saw
facts manufactured every disagreement
doesn't have to be a cause for total war
and we must reject the culture in which
facts themselves
are manipulated and even manufactured
now former vice president mike pence at
the inauguration
not clapping on that one and during many
others and why would he
biden is pointing directly to him not
with his finger but
with his words and it is pence and trump
and their supporters and media
allies that did the manufacturing of
many of those so-called
facts joe biden then telling the folks
that did not support him that he will
also
be their president and asking them to
hear him out
to all those who supported our campaign
i'm humbled by the faith you've placed
in us
to all those who did not support us let
me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
if you still disagree so be it that's
democracy
that's america the right to dissent
peaceably than the guard rails of our
republic is perhaps this nation's
greatest strength yet hear me clearly
this agreement must not lead to this
union
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
and then joe biden saying we will repair
our alliances of course the reason these
alliances need repair
is that they were destroyed by the trump
administration biden doesn't say that
but it certainly implied
we all understand the world is watching
watching all of us today so here's my
message of those beyond our borders
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
not to meet yesterday's challenges but
today's and tomorrow's challenges
so this was the right speech for the
right moment and
very quickly i mean almost instantly in
a sense we shifted
from the ceremonial to the logistical
and to getting things done there are so
many things
desperately needed and shockingly
overdue right now
that there's quite literally no time
to bask in the afterglow of the
inauguration and the afterglow of the
fireworks
the literal afterglow because there's so
much that needs to get done
and that's exactly what i want to talk
about next i told you guys
uh six weeks ago seven eight weeks ago
that there's this growing list of things
that joe biden claims he will do
on day one and i told you that we're
going to hold biden to that i'm going
to tell you on day two whether joe biden
did those things and if he didn't
if the day one priorities get pushed
back to week one or month one or the
first hundred days
that would be a broken promise by joe
biden and i
can't tell you how thrilled i am
to be able to report that joe biden
did it he filed 17 executive orders
yesterday there's a 10 or a dozen more
coming today which have not yet been
signed so i can't report on those
and doing really really important things
much of this is by necessity covid
related
but much more than that so some of the
executive
orders that joe biden filed yesterday on
coronavirus
joe biden law he promised he would do it
and he did it
it's a 100 day masking challenge it's
not a mandate
it's a request that for these next
hundred days as the vaccines start
working their way
through the the population already
starting to see a decrease in
hospitalizations thanks to the vaccines
that everybody wear a mask and indeed a
joe biden did
uh sign a mandate for masks at federal
buildings which is within his purview
joe biden can't mandate masks in state
buildings or in random businesses
or out in in public or in people's homes
and he's not trying to do that but
doing exactly what he promised to do on
masks hundred day challenge
and mandate in federal buildings um
joe biden immediately shut down trump's
withdrawal
from the world health organization that
was a disastrous idea at the worst
possible time
immediately putting dr anthony fauci as
the head of the delegation to the who
in a predawn uh meeting this morning
fauci already meeting with the who
this is i mean in 24 hours how things
have changed
on the economy joe biden has extended
the nationwide moratorium on evictions
and foreclosures until at least
the end of the first quarter march 31st
and he has extended the pause on student
loan payments and interest for americans
with federal
student loans until at least september
30th
of 2021. he has not forgiven any student
loan debt yet
and that's something many of us want to
see him do but this is a big deal as
well
joe biden has rejoined the paris climate
accord a process that will
actually take close to 30 days
immediately reversing what donald trump
did in
bailing on the paris climate accord and
also
joe biden reversing donald trump's
action by canceling the keystone xl
pipeline period
cancelled and directing agencies to
review and reject
and reverse rather 100 trump actions on
the environment i said this must be done
trump's damage to the environment by
loosening regulations has been
disastrous joe biden day one saying
undo all of it um joe biden rescinded
the trump administration's 1776
commission
this was that patriotic education
nonsense that donald trump put in place
that's done he also put in a uh
executive order to prevent workplace
discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation or
gender identity
uh there are a number of other sort of
more minor executive orders but
very importantly joe biden fortifying
daca after trump tried to gut it
reversing the trump administration's
restriction on entry for passport
holders from
several muslim majority countries that's
the reversal of the so-called muslim
country travel ban
undid trump's expansion of immigration
enforcement within the u.s
and stopped construction on the border
wall
very very important stuff
there are a number of other executive
orders that joe biden signed yesterday
and more that he will sign today but
this is all
very good and very important and what is
really important to understand here
and we're going to play some clips of a
triggered fox news host
about these orders soon what we
found out is that a relatively small
number of bad
actors trump included who the majority
of the country didn't vote for remember
even in 2016
trump got less than half of the vote of
those who voted
and half the country didn't vote in
2016. a very small number of
bad actors can do a lot of damage and
now
joe biden gets to undo that damage by
the exact same
legal provisions that trump used to do
the damage many of which were executive
orders
but there's a general principle which is
that it's almost always easier to break
and destroy things than it is to build
things consider building a house
you've got to clear the land and then
dig out a foundation and pour the
foundation
and then frame it and then put a roof on
and windows and doors
and toilets that trump said you have to
flush 10 or 15 times
and then you bring a wrecking ball in
and in 10 minutes you reduce it to
rubble
that is a a a perfect analogy
um to much of how we saw the trump
administration
operate in very little time trump was
able to destroy global alliances
that took decades to build and to
strengthen
trump was able to by failing on the
virus for a few months
irreversibly set us back okay so i think
we understand the concept
a lot of right wingers are finding
themselves very triggered by joe biden's
executive orders let's talk about that
next
this is really great when barack obama
was president
fox news said that executive orders were
tyranny they were tyrannical
when trump became president fox news
said
trump's executive orders are fine
because he has to undo
the tyranny that were barack obama's
executive orders
and now on day one joe biden signed 17
executive orders undoing some of the
worst of the worst of what donald trump
did
and once again fox news host ainslie
earhart
her feelings are hurt it is
wild how everybody's feelings are now
the most important thing
on fox news and she doesn't think
joe biden is acting to unite america
because undoing trump's executive orders
with his own
is mean guys these people
are so childish and pathetic and
predictable take a look at this
so our country's got to come together
and joe biden said yesterday
i want unity he talked about that in his
speech but the first thing he does the
first order of business
is to walk in sit down at the table and
he has 17 executive orders really wiping
away
much of what president trump did so his
supporters are saying how can we have
unity
if you're taking away everything that we
like this is so stupid
that it doesn't even count as as
political analysis
the things joe biden dealt with
yesterday on day one which i am thrilled
to have seen him deal
with we're not just canceling
counterproductive things that donald
trump did
they were things that divided us from
the world if you want to talk about
unity
everybody's in the paris climate accord
we're out
that's divisive other countries are
taking kovid seriously but we have a
president saying it's the flu
and it'll go away like a miracle in 15
cases will be zero
that's divisive in terms of the united
states from the rest of the world
we are going to have four solid years of
these people whining that joe biden
simply isn't continuing everything trump
did
if you follow what ainsley earhart is
saying to its logical conclusion
anything that joe biden does differently
than trump is apparently not unity and
that's right joe biden is not trump
these are the same people
who for four years under trump said
elections have consequences
and you lefties have to deal with it and
they were right during the trump era i
agreed
elections have consequences and that's
why it was tragic that so many leftists
stayed home in 2016. but the 2020
election also has consequences and we're
seeing them now and by the way
if ainsley is correct and on day one joe
biden really did undo everything donald
trump did
that confirms trump didn't do very much
if joe biden
in four hours these were signed within
four hours of joe biden being sworn in
if in four hours biden can undo four
years worth of what donald trump
did donald trump didn't do very much and
we are going just prepare yourselves
this is what fox news
or worse this is what fox news is going
to look like for the next four years
let me know your reaction and your your
feedback to the early days of the biden
administration
i'm on twitter at d pacman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
all right this is really important this
is so important i'm even going to take
my sharpie out for this
i am really glad to have some time today
uh to do a deep dive
on videos from a focus group with trump
supporters this was hosted on monday
night two days before the inauguration
of joe biden
we've been talking about what do we do
now about
75 million trumpists how do we deprogram
and it's really an important insight
into the mind of the trump voter and
what we're up against for these next two
and four years
this is a focus group done by frank
luntz a long time republican focus group
guy
who has been anti-trump for some time
and if we are to understand how to
de-program
trumpists we have to understand how they
ended up believing the things they
believe
and this is the perfect window through
which to do that so let's get right in
we're going to have lots of analysis of
this but
uh let's get right into the first clip
and let me know whether you find this
type of segment useful
raise your hands if you think that
donald trump actually won the election
if all the votes are counted accurately
who thinks he
wants all but
one of you okay denise
where's the number one source for news
for you
i love watching fox news i love
listening to the news because i drive a
lot for a living and i
right now by the way i'm living in
washington dc i'm staying with my
daughter these past two weeks and it's a
nightmare here it's a nightmare
but um i listen to the news i listen to
the news and what i just heard recently
that they're comparing us to the kkk
one of the newscasters the any
republican it's
it's disgusting okay so denise
thinks trump won she likes to listen to
fox news
washington is a nightmare and she heard
that she as a trump supporter is being
equated to the kkk
because she voted for trump so notice
that there's a total lack of awareness
that the reason
washington on monday was a dystopian
nightmare
with troops on every corner is because
of other trumpists
who violently rioted on january 6th and
she says
i've been watching fox news which has
not
actually made the connection that trump
incited
the pro-trump mob that did the writing
so it's really important to see how her
beliefs are directly informed
by how fox did or maybe better said did
not cover the riots the link
between what you watch and what you
believe is very very clear this is not
trivial
let's continue randy where do you get
your news from
what do you watch i used to watch fox
news up until the election
um so now i kind of just looking online
i was getting it from twitter but i
deleted my twitter account once
they censored the president so
now i don't even really know where to
get my news because i don't know what's
true and what's not i don't know what to
believe from anywhere
just like max so there's a lot there
that's just 27 seconds but listen to how
much
telling information is is released there
she
used to watch fox but not anymore
increasingly common among
trumpists she used to get news on
twitter
until they censored trump so notice that
even where she used to get her news
that's not news fox news isn't news
twitter itself isn't news although there
can be news articles posted to twitter
but i would be interested in seeing who
these folks are following on twitter so
it's a lack of media literacy for years
i've been pointing out
rather than just arguing with people
about the facts if we establish a
foundation of media literacy
you insulate people from even falling
prey to a lot of this stuff this is a
perfect example this is exactly what
i've been talking about for a decade
then a guy yells that she should be
getting her news from breitbart and
newsmax another self parody let's
continue
wendy where'd he get your news from
newsmax uh
formerly from fox occasionally i'll
watch the five
um talk radio
so another example of a former fox
viewer
and she says sometimes i will watch the
five
on fox news again the five
is an opinion show on fox which she says
she's getting
news from this is a case study
in everything i've been saying about
media literacy for the last decade on
the show
now frank luntz asks why so many of them
have stopped watching fox news take a
listen
who here has stopped watching fox since
the election
half and half charles why did you stop
watching fox
i started i stopped watching fox a
couple of years back
i just i just saw them sliding further
and further and further to the left
and i and i i have cnn for that i have
um
msnbc for that i don't need fox to go to
the left
so i get my news from breitbart newsmax
meredith why'd you stop watching fox oh
me
i didn't um so much and when you say
news i know where i get my opinions but
news
i you know unless i see it with my own
eyes anymore i don't believe anything
it's pretty terrible actually i don't
know
how do you know the election was stolen
if you don't believe anything
i don't know it was stolen i know that
that when somebody wins an election at 4
00 a.m and people stop voting that's
just not how we do things
fox is too left for the first guy he
went to breitbart
and newsmax meredith doesn't believe
anything anymore that's an example of
when skepticism goes too far
healthy skepticism is good uh
unquenchable skepticism
leads to you believing nothing and it's
completely unproductive so
this is really instructive because our
beliefs about these people
they might seem like satirical
caricatures
but it's literally what they're saying
and what they believe
now if you think that this is useful i
do want to hear from you if you think
these these
to me this is endlessly instructive and
i hope it is for the audience
so now frank luntz gets into beliefs
about a so-called stolen election
and now the the focus group participants
start getting
more agitated that's all we ever wanted
was an investigation we were told to
move along
nothing happened in here just keep
moving don't
look don't ask questions yeah it's
absolutely
we look and we ask questions when we see
a guy who campaigned from his damn
basement had 12 people show up at his
rallies gets 80 million votes come on
yeah it doesn't make sense so i'm
investigating and i look at numbers all
day
and i i when i went to bed at night
pennsylvania had
we were we were up and then when i woke
up
900 000 votes all of a sudden went to
biden and he won by what like three
percent in pennsylvania
it doesn't make sense like if you look
at the numbers
they don't make sense and so then i
listened to the hearings
all the hearings i listened to all
single people talking about it
something happened congress is not doing
their due diligence to investigate this
they don't want to investigate it right
because it'll take forever
it'll take forever no it'll take their
power
to take forever it'll take their power
and then and then when they played when
they played a game like they were going
to do something
they weren't going to do anything they
it's like for the next election
we can come to only one conclusion from
listening to that
and unfortunately it's that the country
is in
real true deep serious trouble
like really really deep remember uh
talking about
hearings those were legally irrelevant
hearings
where no one was under oath none of
their claims were verified period
and that's why she thinks it was rigged
and it keeps going and they start
getting each other more and more wound
up
but we got to live with the results of
this one that was stolen right
right why should we vote tell me why
thank you i mean look at georgia exactly
the same process was used in georgia and
whoopty do surprise whoopi new surprise
the dempsey scott got elected
well what should we do
with hr1 her first bill of the new
congress
is to submit into law the very things
that they use to steal this election
yep and now they've got the majority to
pass it they're going to change the
rules
and keep power that's what i fear for
about my children
is that this is not the america that we
that we grew up in because they're going
to change the rules
just like adolf hitler did just like
fidel castro just like
you shot us it's gonna happen are you
sure you really want to compare
joe biden and the democrats with adolf
hitler you should yeah
it's not the methodology the methodology
absolutely
technology's so there as predicted they
think not only was
georgia stolen from trump it was also
stolen
in january from kelly lefler and david
perdue
it's not even a possibility for most of
these folks that maybe trump lost
and lefler lost and purdue lost and then
of course he raises a comparison between
2021 democrats and adolf hitler
and others in the focus group like it
others in the focus group say yes
that's a correct comparison so this this
is really stunning stuff
and if you're wondering how do you
deprogram that i don't have the answer
the the point here is for us to
understand how deep the programming is
it's horrific
then the topic is how do you feel about
the january 6th trump riots
are you proud of what they did at the
capitol i am sympathetic to what they
did at the capitol i am absolutely
sympathetic because
i feel like i have nowhere to go after
this last election
what am i supposed to do i can't vote
them out
they're going to refuse to be voted out
no term limits no balanced budget
they're going to refuse to be voted out
i'm sympathetic i think the congressman
should be
i think the congressman should be pulled
out and each of them face a tribunal and
face punishment for
what they how they betrayed our country
over all these years
every one of them should have to face
the american people for what they've
done people agree with frank
i'm curious how many people i agree with
frank these guys that should have a
reckoning coming
no that frank not two friends i want to
make it clear
this is agreeing with frank from florida
not me
yeah i know he's coming from i do he he
wants a reckon
he wants to know why these people have
betrayed us and he wants them to stand
up there and say yeah i betrayed you for
money or
power or a chinese spy or whoever it is
in that one i actually am unsure
who they're referring to in terms of
having a tribunal for members of
congress
to me if you say david who needs to face
consequences
it's the republicans that supported the
trump election coup attempts
but i have a sense that those trumpists
are talking about democrats facing a
tribunal i don't know
and in this next clip they say more
about the allegedly
fraudulent nature of the election but
then there's a really
interesting guy here jim from michigan
who doesn't think the election was
stolen
and quit the republican party so listen
to him this is a really important moment
of clarity
and the reckoning is normally an
election but we don't have that anymore
no don't have that anymore powerless you
know i i
um you're listening to all this and um
i left the republican party about
about three weeks ago because of what i
saw at the capitol
i was embarrassed um i was embarrassed
for the president
i voted for him twice i had my lawn
signs out i had my flag up
i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassed because
look at kovid
how that's totally out of control right
now you don't hear from this man anymore
he's pence has got to go around and what
he did to vice president pence
and threw him under the bus i will never
i see that the other way around jim
no i just agree that's dependent friends
could not do anything
under the console but not do anything
pence
did what he had to do pence had two
months
pence had two months before he came out
and gave that letter he had two months
to say
what he thought and he he betrayed us
just like the democrats and the
republicans have
pence had two months and he remained
silent
so that's jim from michigan jim says
trump failed on kovid
he abandoned his own vice president and
jim is embarrassed
so here's the takeaway that's a focus
group with 12
trump voters 11 of them just 48 hours
not even 36 hours before the
inauguration of joe biden
are completely disconnected from reality
and they seem to be beyond reach
11 of those 12 people i don't even know
how we reach them
one of the 12 jim from michigan actually
saw what happened and saw things for
what they are
and said i can't be a part of this this
is wrong and he sort of seems to have
deprogrammed himself
that's really rare and the fact that one
out of 12 people did that is very
important
that may be the proportion that we're
working with in terms of what portion of
these people
can reasonably be deprogrammed and as
you can imagine one out of 12 is not
enough
it's not enough to fix the problems that
we have in this country it's not a great
percentage
so hopefully this is really good work
actually by frank luntz
hopefully this helps us to understand
the issue
and the more we understand it the more
of a shot we have it fixing it and we'll
be talking more
in the coming weeks about how it can
maybe be fixed but as you can see
that's an uphill battle that's a real
uphill battle we'll have more on this
on our instagram page at david pakman on
instagram while you're there
follow me on instagram david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
did you know the david pakman show is on
all sorts of different platforms find us
on youtube
at youtube.com forward slash the david
pakman show
and on steemit the blockchain based
publishing platform
at steemit.com david pakman
that's s t double e m i t dot com
forward slash at david pakman
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today nicholas christaka sterling
professor of social
natural science at yale university and
also
author of apollo's arrow it's so great
to have you on i i'm
glad to be talking to you today david
thank you for having me
so there are so many things that we can
say
about the medical handling of this
global hundred-year pandemic
about governmental failures or successes
vaccine development etc but one of the
things that i find interesting which
you've talked about
are sort of the cultural aspects what we
learned and what was exposed maybe about
american culture over the last nearly
year of dealing with the global pandemic
can you kind of frame that conversation
for us and explain what what we should
be thinking about when we think about
culture and the pandemic
right well i think you already
highlighted one important factor which
is
something i would lead with right away
which is this way that we have come to
live
in this last year and a lot of the
things that have happened
uh for example the death of health care
workers or
a lot of the denial and the lies that we
have seen about the pandemic
many many of these features seem so
unnatural and alien
but it's important to understand that
plagues are not new to our species
they're just new to us we think all of
these things are so
unusual and weird and unnatural and how
can we but that's just not true and in
fact
when you study the psychological
social and economic responses to the
covet 19 pandemic you see
that many of those responses um actually
have obtained
with pandemics and plagues going back
thousands of years
so let me give you a couple of examples
let me start with a really simple one
which is the death of health care
workers
many people are aware of the fact that
you know many hundreds of american
health care workers and thousands of
health care workers around the world
have died caring for patients who are
sick in fact one of the reasons we
should behave better is to reduce
our imposing risk on these people of
dying caring for us
well thucydides in the plague of athens
in 430 bc
talks about the death death of health
care workers pope clement vi
in the bubonic plague in 1347 talks
about the death of
nurses taking care of patients this is
not new
or lies in denial we've seen huge
amounts of like
superstitions about you know you could
use bleach to treat the condition or
or or like you know bill gates is going
to inject us the vaccine has you know
microchips is ridiculous or um or denial
including at the former president you
know the white house saying it's going
away there's nothing happening it's
going away which was completely false
and
known to be false this also this
response
is typical of human beings during times
of plague
because we don't want to believe that
this bad thing is happening to us
and on and on i could go on i mean blame
for example the desire to blame
others is again very typical uh we we
saw this during bubonic plague when
there was anti-semitism you know the
jews were blamed
uh we saw it during hiv you know when
when gay people were blamed or haitians
were blamed or iv drug users were blamed
um there's always this desire to blame
someone else uh
when there's a time of plague anyway i
could go on but there are these
these things that are happening to us or
i'll say one more thing and then i'll
shut up
you know the uh you know there's a lot
of misunderstanding
about what is happening to us in terms
of the economy for example
yes so people think that the economy is
collapsing because of what the state
what the government is doing to us
but if you read accounts of plagues
going back thousands of years for
example
uh uh john of ephesus a priest writing
about the plague of justinian in 500 a.d
talks about how the economy collapses
everything slowed and ceased
people were not out and about there was
no government that was ordering schools
or businesses to close in that period
it's just
this is what the virus does it's stops
social interactions
which therefore stops the economy so all
of these things that we're seeing
are a once in a century event and we
just i think have to accept that and
maturely confront it you know i um i
interviewed
brian greene during the pandemic earlier
in the pandemic
uh one of the things he pointed out was
that
he thinks there's a certain naivete
thinking that if we were to make contact
with intelligent alien species
all of our our earthly problems would
all of a sudden
seem sort of quaint and irrelevant and
we would come together as a as a global
people because now this thing
that transcends our problems has taken
place he thinks even that is probably
naive to think that there would be some
initial
instinct of that and very quickly we
would go back to our normal problems
is there a similar naivete and i think
the answer clearly is yes as evidenced
by the last many months
to think that something like this would
have allowed us to cross the partisan
bickering
and not to devolve into the same sort of
uh
arguments the politically aligned
arguments that we see with abortion and
taxes and so many of these other things
is it just fundamentally naive to think
that something like a global pandemic
would cross those bridges well first of
all let me back up and say there's a
very famous exchange between i think it
was
president ronald reagan and um and
mikhail gorbachev
where uh reagan says to they're having
an exchange about how they can work
together
and uh reagan says well let me ask you
you know if the earth was invaded by
aliens would you come to our defense
and gorbachev says of course you know
and uh
so this this trope this idea that's in
science fiction movies that human beings
would come together
uh to confront a shared threat
is uh actually deeply fundamental and
there's another very famous
social psychology experiment or
demonstration called the robbers cave
demonstration which was taken which took
place in the 1950s where
um 12 11 or 12 year old boys were taken
into uh
a summer camp and divided into two
groups yeah and uh
and then they were their group
solidarity was fostered and then it was
revealed that there was this other group
nearby
and then group competition was fostered
and then the investigators contrived to
have a shared threat
and show that now having created these
divisions they could undo the divisions
the shared threat was they contrived to
have the water supply to the camp
interrupted
so the boys had to work together across
groups you know to fix the problem
so so there's all this background on
exactly the topic that you're mentioning
and it is true that a shared threat can
bind groups together
and many people have for years thought
that a virus or a germ would have that
effect in other words
we all are human we're all facing this
deadly threat
we should uh work together to confront
it
but there are a few features of play of
of epidemics and this one in particular
that make that hard
my guess is my guess is one is that not
everybody agrees to the nature of the
threat
first and partly that's because this
this germ
serious and deadly though it is is not
as deadly as
thank god it could have been just to be
clear we could have been facing a
bubonic plague type situation right now
on the planet
and many people you need to people need
to understand this it's just by the luck
of god that we're not facing something
that's
10 or 30 times deadlier like in the
movie contagion anyway this particular
pathogen
is serious it kills about one percent of
the people that get symptoms from it but
it's not so deadly
as smallpox or bubonic plague which i
think would have galvanized
public interest and maybe helped us
transcend some of our political
divisions first point
second the the the germs struck us at a
particularly vulnerable moment
in the life of our society in terms of
our intellectual life we have as a
nation
lost respect for science we have we have
politicized the notion of expertise we
think that experts are elites who are
trying to take advantage of us
rather than just experts you know like
if you have a car problem i don't think
i'm as good as my car mechanic in
figuring out what the problem is i
want to pay someone who knows more than
i do about the problem and if you have a
surgeon or anything else
there's expertise in the world or a
plumbing disaster there's expertise in
the world
so but we have begun to politicize this
notion of expertise to our detriment we
have high levels of political
polarization and economic inequality
already century high levels when the
virus struck and finally
we have lost the capacity for nuance in
our
civil civil civic discourse people say
oh you're with me or you're against me
or things are black or white but adults
know that that's not true
things are not black or white most
things are shades of gray anyway
all of those things plus the relatively
low
but still high level of death from this
germ
have made it difficult for us to band
together to confront it
plus i think frankly incompetent
leadership in the former administration
at the white house which minimized the
threat and did not act
to protect the public interest i'll say
one more thing and then i'll shut up
again
many people say well okay trump didn't
do so well but you know what about
the england or italy or other countries
it's true many other countries also did
poorly
but many countries did well and not just
rich islands like taiwan and new zealand
germany did well greece did well you
know we're the united states of america
i expected more from us i expected us to
do well
in confronting this threat yeah rwanda
is also an interesting example actually
of a country that that that did uh
quite well certainly better than many
might have imagined if they didn't know
that much about
about rwanda when when we think about
the next year
a lot of the discussions are when will
herd immunity be reached but there's
some pretty interesting pieces that
suggest that the what might be called
the cultural end to the pandemic will
come before
the medical end of the pandemic
particularly if the most at risk
are vaccinated first as is happening and
the deaths go down dramatically so
there's kind of a question as to whether
the cultural and the medical ends will
coincide
what are you looking for in terms of
this next year when you look at
the cultural impact the rollout of
vaccinations the transition to a new
federal administration handling this
well i think you you're highlighting the
key issues there's this notion of herd
immunity
which is this idea that a population can
be immune to a condition
or immune to having an epidemic of the
condition even if not everyone within
the population is immune let's
understand
and and through various calculations and
making an
accommodation for something known as the
network effects probably at least 50
percent of americans have to have
acquired immunity to the condition
before we get hurt immunity now
when that happens the virus is not gone
it still circulates and can kill people
but
we've taken the wind out of its sails
its epidemic force has been
nullified when we get to this critical
threshold now
we have miraculously invented a vaccine
we're the first generation of humans to
confront the ancient threat of plagues
that has been capable to develop a
specific countermeasure in real time
it's amazing but as we're all seeing in
the news we have to
manufacture hundreds of millions of
doses distribute them which is not easy
and persuade people to take them and i
think it'll take at least a year before
we get to 50
or more which is what we really need
vaccination at least 50
meanwhile the virus is still spreading
about 14 of americans are infected so
far
this has a long runway so either way i
think it's going to take another year
before we reach herd immunity and during
that time we're going to have to live in
a changed world with
wearing masks with periodic school and
business closures with
gathering bands with extra hygiene and
all of the headaches that we've come to
be familiar with
and this is before the emergence of new
more communicable strains
which is another complication so i think
at least a year and then
we'll enter the um the intermediate
period where
some of the things that you mentioned
will begin to obtain which is we're
going to have to begin to confront the
psychological social and economic
aftershocks
because let's not forget tens of
millions of americans are out of work
millions of people have lost uh
businesses have closed millions of
children have lost schooling
there's a disability many several
hundred
probably two and a half million
americans will be disabled by this
condition
between half a million and a million
will die so we're going to have a lot of
recovery to do and i think it'll take a
while but come 2024
approximately these are approximate i
think we'll finally enter the
post-pandemic period
and then i think it'll be like the
roaring 20s of the 20th century after
the 1918 influenza pandemic
will have a roaring 20s of the of the
21st century yeah one of the things that
i've not seen discussed that much which
i think is important and interesting is
i i never believe at the time when in
may donald trump was saying
the measures that some want you to take
are more damaging than the virus itself
i thought that was
dangerous and a disaster but i do think
that there is
a an aspect of this which is after a
year
or a year and a half or however long it
is of this feeling that
the world outside of your house is
hostile and dangerous to you
seeing two people close to each other
with no masks looks
like an act of something more than what
it used to be right this
stuff becomes ingrained that doesn't get
undone
in a month or in two months and i'm
curious as to what the long-term
group psychology impacts of that are
going to be that's exactly right
that's what i was suggesting that when
we get to early 2022 we'll finally have
put the biological and epidemiological
impact of the virus behind us but
there's still going to be a lot of
psychological and other recovery that'll
take a couple of years
judging again from the also the history
of past epidemics just like you said
not everyone's going to take off their
mask a year from now right for a variety
of reasons people are going to still be
wearing masks some will be cautious the
virus will still be around
other people have immunodeficiency some
people will have habits they'll be
worried etc
so it's not going to be instantaneous
nor will any of the other recovery be
instantaneous it's going to be a long
and enduring
shock i think what people need to
understand is is we happen to be alive
like our grandparents were alive when
the world was at war
right like when i talked to my uh greek
relatives in greece about this in their
80s
their frame of reference is not like the
typical american
it's it's like a european who's used to
having invading armies my my father
remembers the nazis invading athens
when he was a boy so for him you know
that was like a once in a century event
and now this is another once in a
century event you know
so so i think people need to understand
that
that this is a quite a serious and
unusual experience to us
again for humans have been you know
plagues are in in the bible they're in
shakespeare they're in homer
they're in cervantes you know there's
nothing new about plagues per se but
for us it's quite a new experience and
we have to understand
much as we wish that this had not
happened to us and much as we wish that
it would end quickly
it's not it's just not what plagues do
uh we've been speaking with nicholas
christakis who
is sterling professor of social natural
science at yale university also
author of apollo's arrow i so appreciate
your time today
david thank you so much for having me
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does all day very very concerning to a
lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account at david pakman
show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so we've been talking about how there's
a real question mark as to what
right-wing media is going to look like
over the next two years and four years
in the biden presidency
and we are if if there is any signal
about it
over the last 24 to 48 hours it's that
it's going to be absolutely and
completely nuts now we
covered during the trump administration
fox business host maria bartoromo who
used to be a
very solid reporter on cnbc uh 20 years
ago when i
started watching cnbc as i got into the
financial markets and trading stocks and
the like
and during the trump administration she
became nothing short of a complete and
total trump brown noser doing
sycophantic softball interviews and
repeating
uh the most ridiculous uh conspiracy
theories including over the last two
months that donald trump was going to
figure out a way to be sworn in
for another four years when clearly he
was not and uh
this week she asserts without evidence
that at the january sixth trump riots
there were democrats dressed up like
mega trump people there is no evidence
of this
this is as baseless as it was really
antifa
in disguise it doesn't seem to affect
maria bartoromo's willingness to repeat
it take a listen to this
well security in the nation's capital is
at an unprecedented level this morning
ahead of the inauguration tomorrow
a new report says that some far-right
protesters have discussed
posing as members of the national guard
to infiltrate the inauguration
the way democrats infiltrated uh
two weeks ago and put on maggot clothing
acting secretary of defense chris miller
says that there is no intelligence about
a potential insider threat to the
inauguration
so no one did that democrats didn't do
that
that's a lie uh black lives matter
didn't dress up as trumpists on january
6th
antifa didn't dress up as trumpists on
january 6. there's no evidence for that
whatsoever
and what i see here is maria bartoromo
desperately trying to have credibility
and relevance but lying as usual like
sean hannity
realizing wait a second i used to be
friends with the president
now i'm not friends with the president
anymore i'm out
and she's looking for something to cling
to and
th this claim about storming the k
was it was democrats in disguise
storming the capital on january 6th
it's truly bonkers but what's really
crazy
is this four-year period of being a
brown-nosing trump sycophant and
repeating the most
ridiculous baseless harebrained
conspiracy theories
it seems to have gotten maria bartoromo
a possible promotion
fox news has announced that six hosts
are going to get
informal week-long tryouts to become the
permanent hosts
of the 7pm eastern hour on fox news
which they're going to call fox news
prime time
maria bartoromo is one of the uh hosts
who's going to get a week
trial like an audition of sorts and uh
also getting uh auditions for the 7pm
hour
are fox news contributors katie pavlich
who's a disaster
rachel campos duffy who i've never heard
of former congressman trey gowdy
and commentator mark stein i believe fox
and friends host
brian kilmeade also is going to get a
week trial for that 7 p.m hours so
they are setting up for the biden
presidency they're still
trying to figure out what their approach
is going to be
but if the last 48 hours are any
indication
um the conspiracy theories will continue
the hypocrisy will continue
and the attempted brainwashing of their
audience will continue
and sadly as i've said before because of
the
uh very very low level of media literacy
in this country it works on a lot of
people and it's often just a race
whoever gets the
whoever programs them first it's very
difficult to get them out of it and if
you quote
program people to think for themselves
to have a high degree of media literacy
to understand how to question
where they came to their conclusions how
they came to hold the beliefs they hold
if that's the programming people get
then you have people who think for
themselves and don't fall for this
nonsense
if you program people that everybody
else is lying to you
you can only believe me which is common
in right-wing media and it was common to
what donald trump donald trump would say
you can't believe what you're seeing and
hearing the news is fake
just believe me if that's the initial
programming people get particularly if
they're already adults
um a ship has sailed so uh proverbially
speaking so
uh it's gonna be pretty wild for the
next couple of years and the other
question will be will be will there be
any degree of
antagonism between right-wing media and
what is left of the republican party
after trump left it in shambles and i
want to talk about that next a little
bit
uh one of the real questions that we are
going to
answer merely by observing the american
political landscape for the next i think
in the next few months it will become
clear
is whether the sparks
of a republican civil war that we saw
two months ago
will turn into a fire and there are sort
of two possible paths
forward uh it's conceivable that
right-wing media and the republican
party will realize
whoa we are in real rough shape trump
lost the house
for us in 2018. trump lost the senate
for us
in 2020. trump lost the white house for
us in 2020 we have nothing
so we have to unite we can't have a
republican civil war where right-wing
media and elected officials are on
opposing sides
and even within the republican party
there could be a civil war between
people like mitt romney
uh and people like lauren bobo bobert or
marjorie taylor green right so there's a
number of different civil wars that that
could take place
the alternative is that there is a
republican civil war
where one side of the republican party
accuses the other of not having stood
behind trump enough
of being willing to compromise with joe
biden whatever
and that we see a a civil war develop
sean hannity earlier this week signaled
that he is at least
willing to foment this civil war uh
apparently turning on mitch mcconnell
and threatening
the he at the time he was the senate
majority leader
now he's the senate minority leader
thanks to democrats taking control of
the senate
take a listen to this mitch i will give
you an a plus on getting
constitutionalist judges on the bench
been great on judges but frankly it
looks like it's time now
if you're going to go along with all of
this nonsense we need new leadership in
the u.s senate
you can represent the people of kentucky
you're showing basically right now that
you're the king
of the establishment republicans that
frankly
have always had and remain having
contempt
for president trump and more importantly
the 75 million americans that voted for
him
americans want somebody that will fight
for their values and principles
not scheme behind closed doors with your
buddy chuckie schumer
very republican in the senate so much
like with maria bartoromo
sean hannity's direct line to the
president ended yesterday with the
inauguration of joe biden
he knows biden's not going to take his
calls like trump did
so hannity wants to stay relevant in
some way
and what's going on here is that hannity
believes he's still the decision maker
and the influence peddler now
he may be he may find a way to maintain
that role even though he doesn't
uh speak to the president anymore it
would be really great for the left
to have a battle between right-wing
media and republicans
uh that that is only good for the left
and it's just what joe biden needs to
get going with some momentum republicans
so busy with infighting
that they are unable to uh obstruct
the things that joe biden wants to do to
clean up trump's mess
and um one other funny thing you know by
hannity talks about maybe we need new
leadership in the senate
there is new leadership in the senate
because democrats won the senate and
hannity of course means new republican
leadership
uh but the the new senate leadership is
democrats all together and this is going
to be very very interesting now
for people saying that uh i'm somehow
being hypocritical on this
i'm not i have said before a divided
democratic party with infighting
is bad for democrats and a divided
republican party
is bad for republicans the difference is
i want the republican party to be
divided because it will be bad for them
i didn't want the democratic party to be
divided because it was going to be bad
for the left-wing movement
and so i'm consistent infighting is bad
i just
am going to benefit from republican
infighting and thus
i'm fine with them doing that send me
your thoughts and we'll continue to
monitor this over the next few days
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192
david p here's a funny voicemail i get
that this is a joke
but there's actually something very
serious in it take a listen
hey david tim from chicago here so
jill biden keeps talking about unity and
all that
i mean unity would be really nice but
you know who's going to pay for it right
you know he just took office and this
deficit is already at 27 trillion
dollars
who's going to pay for all this unity
yeah now to be clear
the deficit isn't 27 trillion
it's the debt and the debt is also not
27 trillion it's 23 trillion so
important details
the debt is 23 trillion but the caller
makes a good point which is
does biden get blamed for the 400 000
coronavirus deaths starting today by
right-wing media
does biden get blamed for the deficit
that trump exploded starting today and
obviously you and i realize that after
being in office 24 hours
those things are not yet your fault or
responsibility
but the right is going to go with that
sean hannity already doing a segment
last night saying
you know why isn't biden doing more on
covid they said they were going to do
kovadkovakova on day one he hasn't done
that much that was a broadcast
uh nine hours after joe biden had been
sworn in so
i know the caller's kidding but they
aren't kidding they're really going to
start doing that and this is why again
if there's republican infighting that
distracts them
it's only good for joe biden's ability
to get things done
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we will talk about the bernie
sanders mittens meme that has exploded
since the inauguration we are going to
talk about north carolina
okaying uh a
ban on hairstyle discrimination very
interesting and we will also talk about
men leaving college faster than women
during the pandemic all of those stories
and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman